une nuit de janvier 2002 à minuit 21
précises les pompiers d'Amiens reçoivent
un appel sur la ligne de secours
c'est une opératrice qui répond et elle
a à l'autre bout du fil une femme
totalement affolée qui hurle au secours
[Musique]
c'est des cris terrifiants qui d'un seul
coup arrive dans les oreilles de cette
de cette opératrice ainsi de parler avec
cette personne l'appel du peu de temps
finalement le téléphone est raccroché
le pratique essaye de rappeler ce numéro
qui ne répondra plus jamais
faute de pouvoir localiser ce numéro les
secours ne peuvent rien faire
et pourtant cet appel sera le point de
départ d'une enquête à peine croyable
et se rendre compte qu'ils ont à faire à
un crime presque hors norme
plus les heures passent plus le doute
s'installe l'hypothèse d'un tueur en
série est sur toutes les lèvres
on se dit on a l'ADN de l'auteur donc on
va sortir la ferme ça va sortir
[Musique]
c'est des heures des jours d'enquêtes
c'est un travail titanisme
à ceux qui ont fait mal à ma fille
et je sais que
elle a duré
les choses atroces
[Musique]
en janvier 2002 sur une petite route de
la campagne picarde
un automobiliste fait une étrange
découverte
remarque une voiture en bordure de route
ouverte visiblement accidentée avec le
pas fumier qui est allumé l'autoradio
façade bleu qui est allumé aussi et puis
la portière passager est ouverte donc la
première image de cette affaire c'est
cette voiture accidentée et abandonnée
semble-t-il au bord de la de la
départementale 44 seulement le chauffeur
de ce véhicule accidenté à 5 km de
Péronne dans la Somme est introuvable
le témoin appel immédiatement les
gendarmes
à l'autre bout du fil le gendarme se
veut rassurant il dit à son
interlocuteur écoutez vous savez c'est
il y a pas de blessés il y a personne ça
arrive de temps en temps quelqu'un qui
te la route un accident rentre à pied
chez lui
l'automobiliste décide donc de laisser
la voiture là et de reprendre sa route
et la nuit passe
[Musique]
vers 8h du matin une patrouille de
gendarmes se rend sur place le véhicule
qui leur a été signalé au cours de la
nuit une Peugeot 106 grise et toujours
là
il semble qu'il y ait fait un tonneau
parce que véhicule est accidenté
les clés sont sur le contact
dans un premier temps les gendarmes
tentent d'établir les circonstances
exactes de l'accident
pas de bride glace sur le sur la
chaussée pas de trace de freinage pas de
rien ne laisse penser qu'il y a eu à
un accident avec une tierce personne le
véhicule serait donc sorti de la
chaussée tout seul or la route est une
ligne droite dégagée qui ne présente
aucune dangerosité particulière
grâce à la plaque d'immatriculation de
la voiture les militaires parviennent à
identifier sa propriétaire
on apprend que ce véhicule appartient à
Madame CUNIC Élodie
elle habite à Péronne elle est banquière
et elle a 24 ans
et en examinant sa voiture les gendarmes
font une découverte inquiétante
il retrouve sur la banquette arrière le
sac à main de la jeune femme
[Musique]
se dit pourquoi une victime qui a un
accident seul se retourne avec son
véhicule
sort de son véhicule et laisse son sac à
main
c'est quelque chose qui sont pas
cohérent
pourquoi la jeune banquière est-elle
partie en laissant ses affaires et
surtout où est-elle les gendarmes vont
se lancer à sa recherche
un Péron les enquêteurs se rendent
d'abord à l'agence bancaire que dirige
Elodie Kelly
cette dame n'est pas là
n'ont pas été avisés par elle comme quoi
elles sont en retard ou absente ce matin
donc ils attendent son arrivée les
gendarmes vont ensuite à son domicile
rue des Bouchers donc la porte close
ensuite direction les urgences de
l'hôpital de Péronne
mais là pareil au niveau de l'hôpital de
Péronne il y a pas d'entrée au nom de
pudique Élodie a disparu elle s'est
volatilisée sur la route départementale
44 au beau milieu de la nuit
dans la matinée les gendarmes contactent
le père d'Élodie Jackie cullick on
s'imagine immédiatement que tu es arrivé
quelque chose de grave et puisqu'on a
pas de nouvelles de notre fille qui a
l'habitude quand même de nous téléphoner
en cas de problème
on se dit il y a quelque chose il y a
quelque chose
en fin de journée aucune nouvelle
d'Élodie
l'inquiétude grandit
[Musique]
plus les heures passent plus le doute
s'installe on est plus sur un accident
de la circulation mais là il y a une
disparition d'une personne donc une
suspicion d'enlèvement la presse locale
est alerté un avis de recherche est
lancé
[Musique]
nous publions une photo de cette jeune
femme en disant que ceux ou celles qui
auraient vu cette jeune femme peuvent
nous appeler un numéro qui est donné qui
numéro de la vodka gendarmerie de
Péronne
mais le mystère de la disparition
d'élodiculique ne va pas tarder à être
éclairci
samedi 12 janvier 2002 un ouvrier
agricole se rend à la décharge de la
tombelle à 12 km de Péronne
[Musique]
il découvre ce qu'il croit être dans un
premier temps un tronc d'arbre
sur donc sur cet endroit et en faisant
quelques pas pour s'approcher il va
découvrir assez rapidement qu'il s'agit
en faire en fait du corps calciné d'une
jeune femme
immédiatement l'homme affolé prévient
les gendarmes de Péronne dans le champ
un cadavre
et on arrive en sur place les militaires
découvrent une scène d'horreur on trouve
donc le corps sexe féminin
sur le dos dans une position les jambes
recourbées et en partie calcinée on a pu
tout de suite
identifier et de Dick
et se rendre compte qu'ils ont à faire à
un crime presque hors norme c'est à dire
que la jeune femme visiblement a subi
les pires sévices
comment le corps d'élodiculite s'est-il
retrouvé sur ce terrain vague à 6 km du
lieu de l'accident c'est pas un lieu de
passage c'est vraiment un lieu isolé
caché et que personne ne connaît ou ne
trouve pas inadvertance le lieu de
découverte du corps pouvaient laisser
penser qu'on avait affaire à des gens
qui devaient être du coin ou qui
connaissaient en tout cas bien la région
la scène de crime est passée au peigne
fin et les experts relèvent plusieurs
indices intéressants
on constate la présence d'un préservatif
usagé qui était utilisé
ils vont recouvrir également que
qu'il y a des mégot de cigarettes qui
est pas très loin c'est un indice sont
placés sous scellés et envoyés au
laboratoire de la gendarmerie
les enquêteurs cherchent également des
traces de pneus qui pourraient les
mettre sur la piste d'un véhicule
suspect
il semble qu'il n'y a pas de traces de
pneus récentes qui laissent supposer
qu'un véhicule est venu très récemment
au cours de la nuit sur place
le corps des Lodi est ensuite envoyé à
l'institut médico-légal pour autopsie
[Musique]
dans l'après midi de ce samedi 12
janvier les parents d'Élodie Kodi
reçoivent un coup de téléphone qui leur
annonce la terrible nouvelle
[Musique]
c'est un monde qui s'écroule c'est la
fin du monde pour moi c'est la fin du
monde
jackie cullik est accablé par la douleur
d'autant que plusieurs années auparavant
il avait perdu ses deux premiers enfants
dans un accident de la route
et du jour au lendemain agrément
Élodie était une jeune femme très
appréciée qui faisait l'unanimité dans
son entourage
l'homme est énormément énormément de
qualité personnellement
personnellement je lui connaissais pour
ainsi dire pas de défaut elle était elle
était abordable elle était elle était
souriante
très très intelligente a été spontanée
voici les dernières images d'élodiculite
tournée chez des amis quelques mois
avant sa mort
après des études de droit brillante dans
le Nord Elodie était revenu à 23 ans à
Péronne la région de son enfance
[Musique]
elle va devenir la plus jeune directrice
de Banque de France
et on lui confie la gestion de la banque
de Picardie à Péronne a été toute fière
de revenir au pays pour elle c'était son
pays c'était un retour au pays et de
montrer un peu que ma ses capacités
l'amener à avoir une charge importante
plus elle est très jolie une grande
blonde avec des yeux bleus
elle passe pas inaperçu Elodie Kunik
Elodie et met les sorties et ne manquez
pas de prétendants le meurtrier est-il
un amoureux et conduit connaissait-elle
son ou ses agresseurs ou au contraire
s'agit-il d'une rencontre fortuite
pour le savoir les enquêteurs vont
tenter de reconstituer les dernières
heures de la jeune femme
[Musique]
et pour cela les gendarmes vont d'abord
entendre les proches d'élodicides
de travail nous dit que Élodie et qui a
quitté la banque vers 17h45 18h et
qu'elles le sont rendus donc sur
Saint-Quentin puisque devait passer la
soirée avec un ancien collègue
sur Saint-Quentin
cet ami s'appelle Hervé il est
immédiatement entendu par les enquêteurs
[Musique]
on confirme qu'effectivement que ce soit
retrouvé vers 18h dans un café sur
Saint-Quentin après ils sont allés
manger tranquillement au pavillon de
Shanghai qui est en bas de la Rudy's sur
Saint-Quentin le pavillon de Shanghai
c'est un restaurant chinois du
centre-ville de Saint-Quentin
[Musique]
ensuite de cette de ce dîner ils se sont
rendus pour boire un café ou un thé
parce que Élodie ne lui ai pas d'alcool
et qu'elle repartait chez cet ami Hervé
nous dit que Élodie était
sereine joyeuse ils ont passé une
excellente soirée ils se sont bien son
riz ils ont bien discuté elle
paraissaient pas anxieuse ni préoccupé
par quoi que ce soit donc une soirée
tout à fait classique entre copains et
puis très agréable et puis ils sont
passés une excellente soirée quoi
Hervé affirme qu'ensuite elodie a pris
la route vers 23h40 pour rentrer chez
elle à Péronne à une trentaine de
kilomètres de là
mais alors que s'est-il passé entre le
départ d'Élodie de Saint-Quentin et son
accident de voiture
il n'y a pas eu de témoin direct de
l'accident et d'une éventuelle agression
de cela dans les premières heures les
gendarmes ne savent rien entre 23h40 et
une heure du matin il s'est passé
quelque chose pour l'instant qu'on
ignore
quelques jours après la découverte du
corps d'Élodie les gendarmes reçoivent
le rapport d'expertise de la voiture
première conclusion Elodie roulle était
une vitesse raisonnable largement en
dessous des 90 km à l'heure autorisés
sur cette route
elle est a priori aux environs de 60
km/h sur une route nationale
parfaitement rectiligne à cet endroit là
donc la seule hypothèse crédible c'est
que cette accident a été provoqué par
une cause extérieure
pourtant problème aucune trace de
collision avec un autre véhicule n'a été
relevé sur la voiture d'Élodie
pas il y a pas de véhicule qui l'ont
poussé et il y a pas de trace extérieur
pas de trace externe qui est trouvé sur
la carrosserie de alors après forcément
on se dit mais
est-ce que quelqu'un l'a pas poussé à la
faute est-ce qu'elle a pas été
poursuivie par notre véhicule que ce que
le sien est-ce qu'il y a pas quelqu'un
qui essaie de la pousser à la faute pour
les enquêteurs une poursuite en voiture
et l'hypothèse la plus crédible mais qui
aurait pu suivre Élodie et à quel moment
c'est question restent sans réponse mais
l'enquête va connaître un nouveau
rebondissement
[Musique]
c'est en épluchant les relevés
téléphoniques de la jeune femme que les
gendarmes vont faire une incroyable
découverte
sur ce portable on apprend qu'il y a eu
un appel EMI donc c'est Élodie qui a
composé le numéro du CODIS Damien le
CODIS c'est le centre opérationnel des
pompiers
Élodie les avait appelé à minuit 21
précise le soir de sa mort et
souvenez-vous les secours n'avaient pas
pu intervenir
[Musique]
les gendarmes se procurent alors
l'enregistrement de l'appel téléphonique
lorsqu'on écoute la bande la première
fois
ça vous prend aux tripes
[Musique]
qui appelle au secours on est même plus
dans la bande on écoute plus le son on
est pris par les cris
cet appel de détresse dure 26 secondes
il est de mauvaise qualité sonore mais
les gendarmes parviennent à entendre des
voix d'homme
[Musique]
qui sont ces hommes pour les enquêteurs
pas de doute le meurtrier d'Élodie est
l'un d'entre eux
reste maintenant à localiser doux a été
passé le dernier appel de la jeune fille
elle a passé cet appel au secours sur
les lieux de l'accident alors qu'elle
était encore dans son véhicule ce qui
renforce pour moi d'ailleurs l'hypothèse
que c'est un accident provoqué on sent
que Elodie se dit il va ça va c'est pas
normal que les gens sont pas venus pour
lui porter secours comme si elles
pressentait que quelque chose de
dangereux ou de saler mal se passer et
que c'est le mal se terminer mais comme
si elle était prise d'une peur extrême
malgré ce nouvel indice important pour
l'enquête la bande son du dernier appel
d'Élodie Rossell encore beaucoup de
mystères ça permet pas
fondamentalement de remonter la piste
des agresseurs c'est à dire que on ne
sait pas qui s'agit il y a aucun nom qui
est prononcé
et donc par définition aucune
identification possible à ce moment-là
la bande son de l'appel est confiée à
des experts qui tenteront de faire
parler cet enregistrement et peut-être
dans sa voix un peu plus sur les
agresseurs d'Élodie
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard les enquêteurs
reçoivent le rapport d'autopsie d'Élodie
qui montre à quel point la jeune femme a
vécu l'enfer les légistes nous confirme
que la led a été violée
étranglé
et
[Musique]
qu'elle était effectivement décédé à mon
avis de brûlé
du sperme a été retrouvé dans le corps
d'Élodie et dans le préservatif usagé
prélevé sur la scène de crime
les experts sont formels l'ADN extrait
de ces deux prélèvements ainsi que celui
retrouvé sur le mégot de cigarettes
appartient au même homme
et forcément celui de l'homme qui a
violé le lit
immédiatement les enquêteurs vérifient
si le porteur de cette ADN est
enregistré dans le fichier national des
empreintes génétiques
le profil ADN n'est pas ne peut pas être
retrouvé dans le fichier et donc
l'auteur n'est pas ne peut pas être
identifié en tout cas immédiatement
c'est une déception pour les enquêteurs
qui restent pourtant optimiste car cet
ADN parlera peut-être un jour
on se dit on a l'ADN de l'auteur donc on
va sortir l'affaire ça va sortir ça va
sortir rapidement on va retrouver on va
retrouver l'auteur on a son ADN c'est
bon on va on va y arriver je me dis
qu'on
a affaire des amateurs et que bon il y a
trop de traces on va trouver on va
trouver
les gendarmes sont donc confiants
puisqu'ils ont l'ADN du violeur ils vont
employer une méthode radicale pour le
trouver
[Musique]
tous les hommes de l'entourage des Dodie
doivent se soumettre de manière
systématique un prélèvement d'ADN
à chaque fois ma foi entendre les gens
à vérifier leurs alibi les prélever et
comparer l'ADN
[Musique]
même et surtout l'ADN d'Hervé l'ami avec
qui Elodie avait passé sa dernière
soirée et prélevé
seulement le jeune homme est mis hors de
cause tout comme les hommes de
l'entourage de la jeune femme
[Musique]
cependant dix jours après la découverte
du corps les gendarmes sont enfin mis
sur la piste d'un suspect potentiel
[Musique]
le commissaire de Sakura nous appelle
pour dire comme quoi ils ont placé en
garde à vue un individu et il s'agit
d'un certain Cyril connu de la justice
comme délinquance sexuelle
et justement le soir du meurtre l'homme
rodait dans les rues de Saint-Quentin
pas très loin du restaurant chinois où
Elodie à dîner avec son ami
ils vont rencontrer en plus ce garçon
a agressé à Saint-Quentin pour les
raisons sexuelles une adolescente
qui a été embarqué qui a eu très peur
[Musique]
cette jeune fille a réussi à échapper à
son agresseur l'homme
âgé de 25 ans et donc entendu par les
gendarmes
est-ce lui qui a croisé la route
d'Élodie Kulik ce soir là
nous dit effectivement qu'il a passé la
soirée avec un copain est-ce qu'on fait
des boire un peu à droite à gauche il se
souvient qu'il a agressé quelqu'un Cyril
reconnaît avoir agressé une jeune fille
mais pas Élodie
le suspect mentile car les soupçons des
gendarmes sont renforcés par un autre
indice
[Musique]
lorsqu'ils l'ont arrêté cet individu les
propriétaires d'une voiture rouge et ils
ont remarqué que sur le côté de cette
voiture il y avait une trace de peinture
grise or souvenez-vous la voiture dès le
dit tuliques était une 106 grise
la voiture de Cyril les soigneusement
inspectée mais le résultat est sans
appel la peinture grise ne provient pas
de la voiture d'Élodie
les prélèvements ADN effectués sur le
suspect vont le disculper définitivement
alors qui a assassiné la banquière et
pourquoi à Péronne l'énigme reste
entière
15 avril 2002 3 mois après le drame les
gendarmes reçoivent le rapport des
experts en acoustique ils ont analysé la
bande-son de l'appel au secours d'Élodie
Cully
le travail des experts ça a été de en
quelque sorte de nettoyer la bande la
bande sonore c'est 26 secondes d'appel
de détresse des loticuliques pour
essayer de distinguer ce qui se disait
au moment de l'agression
et les experts sont parvenus à isoler
quelques bribes de phrases
certains évoquent ça va bien se passer
ça va aller c'est des propos qui ont pu
être tenu évoqué et je veux dire c'est
assez confus et c'est vrai que bon les
différentes expertises ne confirment pas
les chacun n'entend pas la même chose on
croit distinguer à un moment l'un des
agresseurs qui dit il faut la finir
la violence de ce terme bon qui sera par
ailleurs discuté par d'autres experts il
faut couper 10 d'autres
il faut couper ça renvoie à
Élodie téléphone on va vers elle on
prend son téléphone on coupe on jette la
batterie
[Musique]
seulement avec ses bribes de
conversation impossible d'établir le
scénario exact du crime et rien ne
permet d'établir l'identité de ces
hommes si ce n'est un détail très
particulier
leur accent plus cette locale Picard ou
Picard ou au proche voir
Nord-Pas-de-Calais mais je veux dire des
gens du cru une seule certitude à ce
stade de l'enquête pour les gendarmes
les assassins des lodiculiques sont des
gars du coin ils ont un accent picard
extrêmement prononcé et puis il y a ce
lieu ce lieu où ils ont abandonné le
corps il n'y arrive pas par hasard c'est
forcément des gars du coin
[Musique]
des gars du coin alors le père
d'élodiculique demande à écouter la
bande espérant reconnaître les voix des
agresseurs de sa fille
malheureusement je reconnais pas de
fautes
[Musique]
je ne porte rien
a priori les voix ne correspondent pas à
des membres de l'entourage d'Élodie
[Musique]
les semaines passent l'enquête piétine
et six mois après la mort de la
banquière un nouveau drame plonge le
département de la Somme dans la psychose
le 8 juillet 2002 sur la commune de
ville-sur-ancre un agriculteur découvre
derrière une meule de foin le cadavre
d'une jeune fille
[Musique]
le major Martin se rend immédiatement
sur la scène de crime une scène
particulièrement choquante
a été en partie dénudée le corps les
parties des membres
disloqués manifestement cette jeune
fille avait victime d'agression sauvage
par un ou plusieurs individus avec les
Violets
un véhicule est passé sur elle a été
darcyco
fait troublant le corps de la jeune
fille a été retrouvé à seulement 30 km
de là où a été découvert celui d'Élodie
Kelly
[Musique]
tout de suite bien entendu on fait un
rapprochement avec Elodie cullik par
rapport au lieu d'agression on s'est dit
et peut-être une équipe là du secteur
qui qui sévit c'est vrai que on commence
à évoquer l'hypothèse d'un tueur de la
Somme
la victime est facilement identifiée
elle s'appelle Patricia Leclerc 19 ans
elle avait disparu deux jours plus tôt
Patricia Leclerc c'est une jeune femme
qui habitait la région qui travaillait
pour l'été si mes souvenirs sont bons
dans une restaurant de restauration
rapide d'Albert et elle faisait la route
pour rentrer chez elle à vélo et c'est
là que qu'elle a disparu c'est le
lendemain que son entourage c'est
inquiété ça disparition et son corps
sera découvert par la suite
c'est étrange le soir du meurtre des
témoins ont croisé Patricia Leclerc sur
son vélo et il se souviennent très bien
avoir vu une voiture garée le long de la
route
vous savez que c'était un véhicule
sombre berline
qui est occupé par une grosse masse
blanche l'avant voilà c'est tout ce
qu'on avait comme si elle ment du
véhicule donc on pouvait supposer que
l'auteur s'était caché là avait
certainement doublé la victime et
c'était Milan en attente qu'elle passe
pour la faire chuter et puis ensuite
l'enlever
seulement les témoins non pas relevés de
numéro d'immatriculation
impossible alors pour les enquêteurs de
remonter la piste de la voiture sombre
alors ils élargissent leurs
investigations on s'intéressant une fois
de plus au délinquant sexuel connu dans
la région
les gens qui étaient connus pour des
affaires de mœurs dans l'arrondissement
de Albert Péronne même en proximité de
l'Aisne ont été identifiés et entendu
également sur leur emploi du temps il y
a eu peut-être une centaine de personnes
que qui ont été entendues dans ce cas de
cette affaire là encore tous les efforts
des gendarmes resteront 20 et ils ne
sont pas au bout de leur peine
car si ce n'est plus tard
l'impensable va se produire
on retrouve un troisième corps le
troisième corps d'une jeune fille le 21
août 2002 on est sur la commune de
Villers-Bretonneux
le corps est cette fois coincé sous une
camionnette volée et abandonnée près
d'une voie ferrée
les découvertes plusieurs traces de
d'armes blanches sur le corps sur le
ventre et les décédé d'une hémorragie
interne les gendarmes ne connaissent pas
l'identité de la victime
il décide alors de faire du porte à
porte dans le village pour se renseigner
c'est donc vers 17h
un collègue parle avec une personne et
avec un homme
et ma fille n'est pas rentrée depuis
hier
cette fille c'est Christelle Dubuisson
18 ans
elle aussi a été tuée au bord d'une
route aux alentours de minuit en moins
de 7 mois les gendarmes sont confrontés
à trois meurtres de jeunes filles sur un
périmètre de 40 km
c'est le triangle noir c'est le triangle
de la mort
trois jeunes femmes tuées de nuit en
race campagne à quelques kilomètres de
distance
tout laisse penser à l'oeuvre d'un
dangereux tueur en série
les gens se disent les jeunes filles
sont agressées par un type qui doit être
fait 3 à 5h donc là on y est
[Musique]
on cet été 2002 la terreur gagne les
habitants de la Somme
en l'espace de 7 mois trois meurtres à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres les uns
des autres les deux premiers crimes ne
sont toujours pas élucidés forcément le
climat se fait lourd dans le nord-est de
la Somme à Villers-Bretonneux
l'hypothèse d'un tueur en série et
surtout les lèvres 20 ans 21 ans donc
elle fait la route aussi donc on est pas
sur elle tous les gens sont
peur alors là celui qui a des enfants
ils ont dit on ne sort plus
[Musique]
quelques jours après le meurtre de
Christelle Dubuisson une marche
silencieuse à la mémoire de la jeune
fille est organisée
[Musique]
cette marche blanche c'est presque une
espèce de d'appel au secours finalement
de la population qui dit faut que ça
cesse on peut pas continuer comme ça il
y a un tueur où il y a des tueurs qui
rôdent dans un périmètre de 40 km comme
ça ça peut plus durer on ne pouvait plus
avoir une quatrième affaire il fallait
tout faire pour que ça ne se produise
plus
face à l'émotion de la population les
gendarmes décident de quadriller la
campagne et établissent des barrages
ainsi il recueille de nouveaux
témoignages
[Musique]
si les témoignages de femmes qui
signalent comme quoi elles ont été
importunées ou que le conducteur qui les
suivait un comportement qui n'est pas
qui n'était pas normal
qui les coller ou qui leur faisait des
appels de fin ou qui doublaient il
faisait une queue de poisson pour les
jeux visuels à s'arrêter
ainsi les enquêteurs parviennent à
identifier plusieurs chauffards tous
sont interrogés leur emploi du temps
vérifié mais sans résultat
[Musique]
sur la route là-bas derrière nous
sommes à la fin du mois de novembre 2002
l'enquête sur le meurtre de Patricia
Leclercq la deuxième victime fait un bon
en avant
grâce au laboratoire les gendarmes vont
pouvoir mettre un nom sur un ADN qu'ils
avaient prélevé sur un vêtement
appartenant à Patricia Leclerc le jour
de sa découverte
il y a un nom qui va enfin apparaître
celui de Jean-Paul Leconte
Jean-Paul Leconte les gendarmes le
connaissent bien cet homme vient de
purger une peine de 17 ans de prison
pour une série de viols
il l'avait entendu et prélever son ADN
comme d'autres délinquants sexuels dans
le cadre de l'enquête sur Patricia
Leclerc
c'est quelqu'un qui qu'on avait
rencontré qui était très serein
qui semblait pas faire pas surpris de
nous voir tout à fait le citoyen calme
posé qui les séparaître rien quoi le
compte habite dans cette maison de
Méaulte un village situé justement dans
le triangle de la mort
les gendarmes vont l'interpeller au
petit matin du 25 novembre 2002 à partir
de cet instant je m'y trouvais
croyez-moi j'étais soulagé lorsque je
l'ai vu menotter et puis
hors des tas de nuit
reste à savoir maintenant si Jean-Paul
Leconte et bien le meurtrier des trois
jeunes femmes
la justice va trancher l'homme est
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité pour les meurtres de Patricia
Leclerc et de Christelle dubuisson
seulement concernant Élodie Kulik le
tueur de la somme n'a jamais été
inquiété car il avait un alibi
incontestable
on découvre que au moment des faits des
ridiculiques il était détenu et qu'il
n'a bénéficié d'aucune sortie donc il ne
pouvait pas avoir participé au meurtre
d'Élodie pour le père de la victime la
déception est immense
pour moi ça s'effondre j'étais je vais
te dire on
tient et puis long il faut il faut
revenir à la réalité la dualité
le compte ne peut pas être impliqué dans
le meurtre du lotus
à la section de recherche Damien les
gendarmes chargés d'élucider le meurtre
d'élodiculique poursuivre donc son
relâche leur enquête
les gendarmes vont devoir tout reprendre
à travers la fameuse cellule d'enquête
qui a été spécialement monté pour tenter
de résoudre cette énigme judiciaire les
enquêteurs se lancent dans une tâche
longue et difficile
identifiez toutes les personnes qui ont
déclenché une borne téléphonique dans la
nuit du 10 au 11 janvier 2002 sur la
zone de l'accident d'Élodie ainsi que
sur la scène de crime c'est plus de
14000 appels recensés donc il faut
identifier voir un peu notamment sur
parmi ces appels il y a des gens qui
sont connus pas connus c'est un travail
colossal qui malheureusement ne donne
rien
la mort d'élodiculite va également
réveiller tous les corbeaux de la somme
les gendarmes reçoivent des centaines de
lettres d'anonymes qui leur indiquent
une piste éventuelle écrivez petite
lettre en disant vous devriez vous
intéresser à Pierre à Paul Ajac toutes
ces lettres ont été prises en
considération il faut savoir que
derrière chaque lettre c'est des heures
des jours d'enquêtes au total ce sont
plus de 600 pistes qui seront exploitées
5500 tests ADN et 10 000 auditions mais
tout cela ne donne rien
j'y crois
moi
je me dis on a quelque chose parler ça
risque de parler un jour mais ça va être
ça va être très très long alors Jacky
Kulik prend une initiative étonnante il
va offrir une récompense de 60
000 euros à toute personne qui
permettrait d'arrêter les assassins de
sa fille
[Musique]
je sais bien que Paul les assassins qui
viendront
spontanément c'est désigner eux-mêmes
mais que des gens qui ont des doutes aux
alentours peuvent être attirés par
l'argent des gens qui vont dire ah moi
je sais et qui sont rien qui savent rien
en vérité mais Jacky va s'accrocher à ça
et ça ne marche pas là non plus j'ai
promis pour les oreilles j'ai promis je
voulais dire je reviendrai si elle était
mais
on les aura on les aura
les années passent
mais aucune piste sérieuse n'apparaît
[Musique]
en 2011 9 ans après le meurtre d'Élodie
un nouveau gendarme intègre la cellule
d'enquête de la terre
cette nouvelle recrue est un
scientifique à la pointe de la recherche
en matière criminelle
lui jeune
avec un œil neuf avec ses compétences
peut-être
pourrait-il nous aider sur quelque chose
[Musique]
et ce capitaine propose d'expérimenter
une méthode inédite pour exploiter l'ADN
masculin retrouver sur la scène de crime
la recherche de l'ADN apparente
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de rechercher non pas l'ADN
de l'auteur directe de l'agression mais
de quelqu'un de sa famille quelqu'un
apparenté
[Musique]
et cette méthode utilisée pour la
première fois en France va être payante
car en novembre 2011 le fichier des
empreintes génétiques révèle un ADN
apparenté c'est à dire appartenant à un
membre de la famille du violeur
moi trouvé que un certain Monsieur Viard
un proche de celui qui a trouvé sa scène
de crime c'est pas le même mais c'est
très proche
donc le violeur d'élodiculite ne peut
être qu'un membre de la famille de ce
monsieur Viard
ça peut être qu'un enfant de Monsieur et
Madame bien
la famille Viard vie près de 50 ans dans
l'Aisne et ils n'ont qu'un seul fils en
âge d'être impliqué dans le meurtre de
la banquière
cette personne dont l'ADN et sur la
scène de crime c'est un jeune homme qui
s'appelle Grégory Viard
Grégory Viard avait 23 ans au moment des
faits
[Musique]
c'est un véritable coup de théâtre dans
l'enquête pour la première fois depuis
10 ans les gendarmes tiennent enfin une
piste sérieuse
une grande joie intérieure les gens de
la cellule sont on va dire c'est bon on
tient un bonbon on a la bonne ficelle
seulement pour les besoins de l'enquête
les gendarmes garderont l'identité du
violeur secrète pendant plusieurs
semaines
le 8 janvier 2012
j'acciculique qui n'est pas encore au
courant de ce rebondissement organise
une marche de commémoration pour les 10
ans de la mort d'Élodie
qui me fait tenir c'est le fait de les
avoir un jour de savoir qui ils étaient
pourquoi ils ont fait il y a rien au
pire que de ne pas savoir
rien n'est pire que de ne pas savoir
[Musique]
ce n'est donc que huit jours plus tard
que Jacques et Cully apprendra que le
violeur de sa fille aurait été identifié
je t'en soulagement c'est un grand
soulagement je
me dis on va enfin voir le bout du
tunnel on va enfin arriver je vais enfin
arriver à te dire ma promesse mais
l'espoir de voir le violeur d'Élodie
arrêter
s'effondre immédiatement
car Grégory Viard est mort peu de temps
après le meurtre d'élodiculite
c'était en novembre 2003
un accident de la route inexplique il
était au volant de sa voiture il roulait
à vivalud et à un moment donné il s'est
déporté sur la gauche il est allé sans
castrer sous un poids lourd
des gens diront
c'est un suicide des gens diront que
c'est un accident de circulation en
l'État veut dire bon
nous c'est un accident mortel de la
circulation
on peut les deux hypothèses sont
plausibles
Grégory viar est mort il ne sera donc
jamais jugé et l'action de la justice à
son encontre est définitivement éteinte
cependant l'enquête continue car grâce à
la bande son les gendarmes savent que ce
jeune homme n'était pas seul le soir du
meurtre
on se dit que s'il a été impliqué dans
le drame d'Élodie cunique peut-être
qu'il avait des compli c'est que
forcément les gens qui ont participé à
l'agression d'Élodie faisait partie de
son entourage proche comment il vivait
avec qui vivait avec qui faisait la fête
avec qui sortait qu'elles étaient ses
habitudes est-ce que c'est insolitaire
est-ce qu'il était plus avec Pierre avec
Jacques
alors pour tenter de démasquer le ou les
complices de Grégory Viard les gendarmes
se plonge dans la vie privée du jeune
homme
c'était pas un criminel il était connu
je crois pour les histoires
d'escroquerie il avait peut-être fait
quelques petits larçants mais je veux
dire bon c'était pas c'est pas un
criminel je gère rien supposer que qu'il
est commis ce genre de meurtre pourtant
au fil de l'enquête la personnalité de
Grégory Viard apparait de plus en plus
contrasté
de sport mécanique de voiture parfois un
peu un peu violent quand il a bu un coup
de trop les soirs de l'histoire de fête
ou le samedi soir un peu turbulent il
sortait pas mal il picolait beaucoup
quelqu'un de discret très violent
j'avais coutume de dire que c'était un
bourrin un portrait confirmé par la
compagne de Grégory Viard au moment des
faits pour la première fois elle accepte
de se confier face à une caméra
tout au début ça allait très bien entre
nous deux après il y a eu son père qui a
été incarcéré là il a commencé à être
violent
à me taper à m'enfermer il allait voir
ailleurs
et
de plus en plus agressif il buvait
beaucoup
en décembre 2012 cet ex-compagne de
Grégory Viard est placé en garde à vue
les enquêteurs s'interrogent sur son
rôle le soir du drame car aussi
incroyable que cela puisse paraître
l'ADN de cette femme a été retrouvée sur
la scène de crime
[Musique]
on a en fait
dans le préservatif la trace de l'ADN de
Grégory Viard et la trace de l'ADN de sa
compagne de l'époque alors les gendarmes
demandent à la jeune femme de
s'expliquer
[Musique]
vivez chez mes parents il venait à la
maison donc moi j'ai expliqué en disant
que en se voyait encore toute façon
c'est comme ça que l'ADN est arrivé sur
les lieux du crime suite à l'ADN
transporté elle vivait avec lui et
partir au moment où vous viviez avec
quelqu'un forcément vous avez des
contacts et bien évidemment que c'est
dans ces conditions que sont ADN a pu
être transporté par Grégory Viard sur la
scène de crime voilà ça s'arrête là
l'ex-compagne devient est donc mise hors
de cause mais son témoignage et une
enquête approfondie dont l'entourage de
Grégory Viard vont permettre aux
gendarmes de lancer un coup de filet
[Musique]
le 16 janvier 2013 les gendarmes lancent
une série d'interpellations dans l'Aisne
ce jour-là cette personne sont arrêtées
dans le cadre de l'affaire Élodie Cully
[Musique]
cet homme qui ont tous des amis de
l'ont fréquenté avant sa mort ces hommes
partagés avec Grégory Viard la même
passion pour les sports mécaniques ils
sont tous placés en garde à vue et au
cours de cette de cette série
d'auditions en garde à vue
les enquêteurs vont ressortir le fameux
appel téléphonique
l'appel à LED de d'Élodie cullik le soir
de son agression
[Musique]
sur cette bande les acousticiens avaient
identifié avec certitude la présence
d'au moins deux hommes certainement les
assassins d'Élodie
et c'est en écoutant cette bande son que
certains des suspects placés en garde à
vue vont faire des révélations capitales
sur les 7 gardées à vue 5 c'est pas rien
5 vont reconnaître formellement la voix
d'un des garder à vue qui s'appelle
Willy Bardon
Willy Bardon 39 ans est un ami proche de
Grégory Viard
les gendarmes lui font aussitôt écouter
la bande son de l'appel d'elody et
l'homme va fournir plusieurs versions
au tout début il reconnaît savoir quoi
dire
il a été surpris de voir que il y avait
une voix qui avait éventuellement des
intonations qui pouvaient ressembler à
la sienne mais à aucun moment donné il
dit c'est ma voix ça y est c'est moi non
c'est une voix qui ressemble à la mienne
mais je ne dis pas que c'est ma voix et
en tout état de cause je n'y étais pas
Willy Bardon et les hommes qui ont
reconnu sa voix sont ensuite confrontés
chacun va dire en écoutant la bande face
à vous débordons si c'est ta voix c'est
toi c'est toi qui est sur cette
enregistrement tu étais donc là au
moment des faits donc c'est quelqu'un
qui vit extrêmement mal à la chose qui
se tourne vers les gens en disant mais
tu me connais je suis pas capable de ça
tu vois bien que ça me correspond pas tu
te trompes c'est pas possible
à l'issue de sa garde à vue Willy Bardon
est mis en examen pour séquestration
viol et meurtre
[Musique]
il est aussitôt placé en détention
provisoire à la maison d'arrêt d'Amiens
première mise en examen dans ce dossier
Willy Bardon un suspect sérieux qui
malgré tout continue de déclamer son
innocence en tout cas au moment où on se
parle alors coupable ou innocent
toujours est-il que jusqu'à son
interpellation Willy Bardon était
inconnu de la justice
il vivait depuis plusieurs années ici
dans le village de Violaines quelques
kilomètres de 50 il décrit comme un type
un peu violent quand il avait bu
lui aussi il fait partie du club de 4x4
du coin il est copain avec Grégory Viard
et toute une bande de de loustiques là
qui traînent qui écume les bars du
secteur il a le coup de poing facile il
a tenu un bistrot dans un petit village
du département de l'Aisne ça apérité au
bout de quelques mois et finalement
l'affaire à lamentablement sombré
au cours de l'enquête de personnalité
sur Willy Bardon les gendarmes
découvrent aussi que l'homme a parfois
un comportement déplacé avec les femmes
certains disent et témoignent que il a
déjà poursuivi des jeunes femmes en
voiture que il a fait des propositions à
des mineurs enfin il est présenté et en
particulier sur le plan sexuel comme un
individu pour le moins peut
recommandable c'est quelqu'un qui n'a
jamais été condamné c'est quelqu'un qui
arrive aujourd'hui à 40 ans avec un
casier judiciaire vierge vous n'avez
aucune affaire sérieuse qui tienne la
route qui viennent dire Monsieur X est
venu embêter x tel ou telle personne a
suivi tel ou telle personne
alors Willy Bardon est-il le complice de
Grégory Viard
pour l'instant aucune preuve matérielle
ne permet de l'affirmer dans l'ensemble
des prélèvements ADN qui ont été
effectués à ce jour aucun je dis bien
aucun
ne concerne mon client la seule charge
sérieuse qui pèse sur Willy Bardon c'est
donc cet enregistrement de l'appel
d'Élodie
alors de nouvelles expertises sont
demandées par la juge d'instruction
on a pris la voie de Willy Bardon on a
enregistré Willy Bardon et on essaye par
la technique de croiser avec la
bande-son pour voir s'il s'agit des
mêmes voies
fin mars 2013
l'ex-compagne de via est à nouveau
entendu par les gendarmes pour la
première fois la jeune femme est
confrontée à l'appel au secours
d'élodiculic et elle est formelle elle
reconnaît les voix de Viard et Bardon
j'ai reconnu tout de suite mon ex et son
copain
son meilleur copain
j'ai écouté la bande je l'ai pas écouté
qu'une fois je l'ai écouté plusieurs
fois
et je sais très bien que c'est
pourtant j'avais peur de me rappeler
leur voix tout ça mais
sur sur
aujourd'hui 11 ans après les faits
l'instruction se poursuit car aucune
preuve formelle n'a permis de mettre en
cause Willy Bardon
l'homme crie toujours son innocence et
il subsiste de nombreuses zones d'ombre
dans cette affaire
est-ce que c'est un crime fortuit
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils sont prielles
Élodie est-ce que c'était un guet-apens
est-ce que c'était parce que c'était une
jeune femme qui se trouvait au mauvais
endroit au mauvais moment
mais surtout principal inconnu dans
cette affaire qui a tué Elodie cullink
Grégory Viard Willy Bardon ou un
troisième homme que personne n'a jamais
réussi à identifier
cette affaire aboutira-t-elle à un
procès c'est en tout cas ce que le père
de la jeune femme espère depuis plus de
11 ans
je ne suis préparé vous savez je suis
prêt je suis prêt à un brosser pour moi
ce que ça représentera
j'aurais tenu parole
j'ai donné ma parole que j'aurais
les assassins quand les traduire en
justice et pour moi ça sera
l'aboutissement
[Musique]
cela fait 4 mois que Willy Bardon est
incarcéré
dans l'attente d'un éventuel procès il
reste présumé innocent
[Musique]